ask me yeah and I told him yeah I was
like yeah I'm in recovery and then uh
because the movie that we did is a um
very heavily it's a it's a sober movie
yeah so everyone on it was like you know
Theo was sober now I'm sober um you
don't have to be sober to enjoy it
what you don't have to be sober you
don't have to be sober to enjoy it right
um yeah how great was he amazing dude
dude that that's someone I met who right
away I was like what a cool dude he's so
cool like offer it he was just nice no
ego yeah you know what I mean yeah he
wasn't always like that
it's when he got sober he start in fact
I want to get him on this that would be
fire that would be fire dude he's a
completely different guy yeah you might
have to add a lot of [ __ ]
I know he's wild you know the [ __ ] that
he was doing when we were shooting oh my
God I'm like a lot of this no like I
would be acting and he's has a crust of
a pizza he's literally run across from
me and I'm acting in a scene and he's
blowing the crust
I mean in front of you know I mean that
kind of guy you're trying to like me in
the moment be in the moment like it's a
serious scene Johnny's like crying yeah
and I'm trying to like you know get
throwing paper at someone yeah he's
throwing paper at somebody yeah he's
that guy but um but when he's acting now
oh my God remarkable natural dude bro
right crazy crazy like it's crazy to see
because like I said it's only my second
movie but like in the first movie I did
when everyone turned it on what was the
first movie It's called Good Girl Jane
and like I went to went to Tribeca we
won in like our category like best film
and then the the main actor she won best
best like actress so wow it was fire and
then so I saw
uh he knows my girlfriend they were
talking he's like oh I still move your
boyfriend's in I think he killed it I
think I have a role for him would he be
willing to audition
so that's how that happened you
auditioned yeah but being clean was like
a big thing it was like an important
thing for him yeah like I think he would
have taken me either way but you know
you don't want people in a sober movie
[ __ ] nodding out no exactly not like
dumbfounded falling asleep every day
falling asleep
while people are in the scene
[Laughter]
right no not not just closing his eyes
asleep why though
just tired yeah yeah just tired tired
tired yeah you'll be honest I think the
the heat because a lot of it was hot
that one day four of us fell asleep the
one in that one scene when we were
upstairs all right
I fell asleep I saw you fall asleep
you're right you're right my bad I did
follow sorry I felt myself going like
this yeah and then I'll show you I'm
gonna show you something I think Eric
said he fell asleep yeah yeah he did I'm
gonna show you something
um check this out
foreign
took a photo of you sleeping of me
sleeping during like a very serious yeah
and so now Johnny Johnny got right next
to you so Johnny is right next to me
he's doing lowering his heart out
pouring his heart out and I'm fully
and then when he saw the photo you know
I mean he laughed yeah but I was I'm so
sorry dude he's like fine you know what
I mean but we did fall asleep dumb phone
I'm sorry but but when I saw you he was
saying something serious and you you
went like you were like this yeah and
then you went
so you kind of played it off as if maybe
you were like pondering oh wow
bro I I act in my dreams I think you're
that good that's how good I am doing I
act when I'm asleep life hack yeah it's
a life hack I think you're that good
right no I think what happened was this
right I was falling asleep right
and and then also something in my head
was like you're in a movie
that's I think that's what but the way
you open it because I'm like looking
back you know yeah yeah the way I was
positioned and and you kind of just went
like
[Laughter]
so let's go back to the hip-hop yeah so
then so you were hip hopping in the van
right you're at a dispensary right
you're yeah and it's like it's like so
my homie he can make merch designs and
make money wherever he is you know so
for him it was easy
and I might yo [ __ ] this manager and
[ __ ]